foreign
[Music]
can you hear me
okay just making sure everything it just
heard your thing pop up like multiple
times because I didn't have the
[Music]
thank you
what's going on you guys gave me out
here coming at you for another video oh
my bad what's up guys it's Lord addict
here with another attic show you guys
have to apologize I just got back from
Philadelphia uh it's been a long drive I
literally just walked through the door
like an hour ago but you know you know
dirt I was considering not having the
show today
but wow it's on the way back
the Xbox raising prices dropped and I
was like I can't miss this day like you
know obviously we got some Final Fantasy
16 stuff to talk about we got some you
know rumors going around you know uh
anything that
dirt himself wants to talk about but
what's going on you guys
welcome to the actual we talk about the
past present future game I got my
co-host with me Dirk griggity what's
going on there what's up man Xbox
raising those prices oh
I cannot TTS
about Sony raising their console prices
but it's all good we'll talk about it
brother yeah we we we got a we got a lot
of stuff to go over we we're it's like I
said we're gonna talk about some you
know relatively small rumors uh we are
also going to talk about the fact that
uh you know Final Fantasy 16 is having
good reviews but King is in the IOP chat
going crazy about 720P
so uh I guess we'll talk about that a
little bit and then you know obviously
we'll talk about the the unfortunate
thing that uh Xbox decided to not
necessarily take away all the uh all the
height they just got but they definitely
they they they they dragged it back in
the water a little bit and brought it
back up but you know first thing we're
talking about this this rumor going
around that people can fly is actually
making a new game I don't think we
talked about this last week no yeah no
we didn't because I think it hit after
after last week's show yeah so
I want your opinion what you think it is
and what you want it to be I think those
are two different questions and I'm very
curious to hear your opinion on the
matter
hmm
now people can fly is of course the
developers that made Gears of War
judgment right in on Xbox 360 they are
so many outriders which I loved I
absolutely love outriders spending still
with my homeboy sean786 but
the question you asked me
what do I think they're making and what
do I want them to make okay fair enough
what if I think the answer to both of
those questions is the same thing
uh Gears of War collection
we've been hearing rumors about that for
the longest
um I think that makes a lot of sense
because this team is familiar with the
Gears of War franchise like I mentioned
they did judgment a lot of people hate
on judgment I think it was mostly
because of the multiplayer and it was a
little bit different but I thought it
was fine
um
I would like that I would like for them
to be making uh Gears of War collection
because look man years
is a great franchise we haven't had a
gear since 2019 some people have been
asking for years uh like year six like
where's gear six I think a lot of us can
we kind of like anxious to see yo
where's gear six we're we're ready we're
ready now even though gears is coming
out every three years last generation
this has been four years and probably in
gear six probably won't come out to
2025. so if they were able to do a gears
collection
I think that would be great dropping
next year maybe hopefully I don't know
I'm just talking right now but I do I
think that would be cool do you think
that it's a possibility maybe it's a
deal to make like an outriders too
coming to Xbox because I I did feel like
Game Pass was able to put a lot of shine
onto that game I think it's one of the
the times where games the screen you
still on that no I don't think they own
the IP I think they funded I don't think
they own oh now that I would like that
if all right because I enjoy outriders I
really did
if people can fly is doing outriders too
for Xbox exclusively you know yeah
that's a pretty good deal to me yeah
because I I know the that our Riders to
score enix's
you know perspective was a flop but I
think if you put that title and what it
did in any other hands than any other
publisher that they're gonna have a
different outlay and a different
perspective because score Enix has been
known over and over again to have like a
a unrealistic expectation when it comes
to their platform uh their games and
what their games should sell I remember
you know when it came to what's that
game you know tomb Raiders they wanted
like 10 million plus I remember they won
the Final Fantasy 15 to sell 10 million
plus like that that's what we're getting
this like weird position where is it
really that it needs that to make profit
or is that what you have promised your
shareholders in profit because those are
two different things one you're sitting
on a mountain of money and two you have
enough money to buy the mountain
and I think that people need to
understand that there's a difference
between projected cells and what they
promised people
and score Enix you know we see a lot of
their smaller titles make a you know not
necessarily the most when it comes to
cells and I think
do you think when it comes to Square
Enix they only had those expectations
with like the Western type of games that
they were making because I think that
they did have those with Final Fantasy
but I do think that's realistic for
those for a title like Final Fantasy to
sell something like that so I think
that's more realistic than expecting
outriders to because outriders sold well
it was like 3 million or something like
that and they still sold that but I know
it it got played a lot in Game Pass and
it's like if you if it still hasn't made
enough money for
people can fly to see royalties yeah
yeah first off that I can't 100 say that
square enix's fault because it's like if
scoring Enix gave you these
recommendations these conditions and
gave you this contract and you still
signed it your Justice blame is them you
know you you are to blame for being
great uh for uh they are to blame for
being greedy and you are to blame for
making a dumb decision uh that's like
equivalent to you know you going in
because you want a house
you sign a crazy you know interest rate
for that house and then when they start
asking for they money you're like but
that's not fair look it's never not fair
but at the end of the day you sometimes
you don't take the first thing that
comes to you or maybe that they shopped
around a bunch and they and greatness
was the only people willing to work with
them but we don't know that and I can
only go off speculation right
so you know I I think I think when it
comes to that I I don't think it's I
don't think it's a gears game
yo okay I mean I mean well that's the I
mean that's just me you know you asked
me if I was hoping yeah I do hope and
I'm kind of thinking but yeah I mean
listen I can obviously be wrong if you
don't think it's good I would like
outriders too though
I don't know if it's outriders too but
what I will
comment on is
uh some some dude on Twitter made
um
a guess and he kind of like worded it
like it was facts
he was like it's gears and we've known
that for a while and then Jazz commented
on that and said I don't like
misinformation it kind of makes me think
it might not be a gears because you know
guys is wrong on some things but for the
most part he does got pretty correct
sources so it makes me think it might
not necessarily they didn't say it was
the Xbox on IP though
yeah it can be outriders yeah like not a
lot I'm thinking about it they did say
it was an Xbox on IP okay so you know
actually let's
let's talk about that Xbox
and Nintendo
IPS
I'm doing the time stamp for the
timestamp mafia
yeah you know how much they uh they love
to complain about free content
uh all right so did you watch the
Nintendo Direct I don't know did you
hear anything about the Nintendo Direct
I heard it was good saw some of the
announcements but that's about it
so let me get this Super Chat real quick
two dollar Super Chat from uh c-dub I
understand raising game pass but console
prices will get to that here momentarily
so Nintendo Direct announced
um the Mario uh Super Mario RPG I would
say that's like one of the most iconic
games that's on Nintendo that a lot of
people have been wanting for a long time
and Nintendo has done that do you think
Microsoft is failing its fans on older
IPS coming back in like a like a
Resident Evil matter or you know high
quality remake
um I wouldn't say the word failing
I would say there's a couple IPS I can
think of that people I've heard people
ask for
panzo Kazooie which me personally I can
care less but killing stink is one I
really do
want to see come back so I wouldn't say
the word failing but I would say that
I believe they they should consider
bringing
those those two games back because those
are the two games I hear people always
talk about I mean they they consider in
the past like last generation they were
going to do a phantom does reboot and
that game wasn't even that popular
um but unfortunately it got canceled
so they've done it in the past so I
would like for them to do that again you
know I'm not going to say they're
failing there you know like failing the
fans but I would like to see them bring
some OIP back absolutely yeah I agree
with you I don't think they're
necessarily failing but I do think that
when you see the demand that some of
their older IPS Mech Warrior or whatever
that game's called make assault
um Banjo-Kazooie
conquer you know they got a lot of yeah
hardcore IPS that I feel like
battle toads yeah it seems like they
just bring stuff back that like Phil
Spencer loved like like
will it sell gangbusters no but to me
like that is what you sold Game Pass and
how it operates as is the ability to be
able to take risks and have them pay off
because you're getting that constant
Revenue stream to be able to go out and
get these games and have these games
developed and if they don't perform the
greatest you have that money to fall
back on so it's like you know you well
Mario Super Mario RPG sell great
probably but it's just like
even if it even if Nintendo didn't think
it would they still went out of their
way to redo and you don't have to do
this to a lot of ips I would say there's
only like maybe four IPS that Microsoft
owns well that's if they don't buy
if they buy Activision that number goes
up dramatically right but as of right
now how hard is it just to have someone
go
redo the original banjo-kazoo you don't
need a new one just yeah do the original
Badger Kazooie gauge some form of
interest in it see how much you how how
much that would actually do or you know
in Game Pass in general see how many
people download a place and people buy
it on PC and then go from there but to
me it's like they're taking upon
themselves to make that decision for us
that you know we wouldn't
we wouldn't you know support that it's
like equivalent to the jrpg thing is
jrpg is going to sell well on on Xbox
probably not right now because we
haven't really cultivated that type of
game on the Xbox ecosystem but in the
future tense if you start getting more
and more of these games on you'll start
seeing more and more sales because
people are actually getting the game
you know you they went above and beyond
for that thing so it's like at this time
it's like go ahead
and just take a shot like I would say
banjo kazoo is probably one of your the
the safest bet you can have someone
remake the first one one for one if you
want to maybe use some Modern
controllers and then just go from there
yeah
um yeah I understand what you're saying
um
you know I'm be honest I don't like
there's been some smaller games lately
um like that was the Streets of Rage
four I really love that one
um you know Hi-Fi Rush is a double a
game I really love that one so I'm okay
if they bring back some of these games
not killings thing I expect that to be a
triple A game but like something like
conquer or or banjo if they brought it
back in like you know like a you know
not a huge Triple A game because how can
you make those games a triple A game in
it anyway I like the battle toll gang
Toad's game the only thing I didn't like
was towards the end it got a little bit
too mini gaming
but I actually liked it
um so if they brought back someone's IPS
I would I would be
happy about that and then
yeah Killer Instincts the AAA product
don't don't try to like save money when
it comes to that like yeah make that one
triple X you see you see like Mortal
Kombat and stuff's doing it's like these
games are desired and it's just like to
me you know
reach out to the people who because I
don't think Nintendo in-house makes
Super Smash Brothers I think another
company does so it's like if that's the
case hire some former devs that worked
on Super Smash Brothers and you they can
make the ultimate Super Smash Brother
with all the IPS they own Master Chief
the gears characters like look those
type of games as games and service maybe
isn't the most profitable and right now
you've had a bunch of them being shut
down but just like in Game Pass
something like that where you constantly
get the characters if you it's a free to
play and if you're not part of Game Pass
you have to buy them I feel like would
work out well for them but I don't know
what type of money they can
realistically make on that so we got a
10 super trap from cdub
Xbox will be uh service only soon Game
Pass is more important than the console
Microsoft focus is software I got rid of
my Xbox months ago and upgraded my PC
PS5 deck I guess stream deck PC is all
you really need I mean I I get what
you're saying on that but I don't agree
at the same time PC is full uh it's like
a mountain and an ocean full of cheaters
can't really go on any of those massive
multiplayer games that doesn't have a
lot of you know protection when it comes
to a form of anti-cheating software and
look is it every game no but almost
every game I've ever played on PC has
been ruined by the online community in
one one way shape or form yo I've said
I've made an example multiple times you
know Fall Guys
that could be literally the farthest
that you can get away from a competitive
standpoint of a game but people felt the
need to cheat in Fall Guys
so until that is handled and uh and
people what's the first thing they say
dirt but but addict
people cheat on Console do you think
it's do you think it's anywhere as bad
as it is
way more cheating on PC man because it's
way easier it's it's extremely easy to
cheat on on PC it's so easy that all you
have to do is put in your credit card
and download a software on a variety of
websites and they will give you the
cheat software for it because because
Bungie is going after these people right
now so like don't sit here and tell me
that it's like the like I will say that
consoles have an issue with aimbots and
stuff like that
but you know that that's that's a given
but I will say like playing Destiny
playing uh you know fall guys playing
these online games I've came across
cheaters on on Console but it's very
very far between there's a point
dirt where I was playing Destiny on the
PC almost encountering a cheater every
other game
yeah
The Fall Guys Fall Guys wasn't the
wasn't much better either so you know I
get it and people say somebody together
yeah
um so to see dub say you know the Xbox
service how long has people been saying
that Xbox will be service only real soon
I think people have been saying that
since 2015. um listen
um
Microsoft focus is software
okay
I mean
I don't get it but
you know I think people think that
they're going to be in the software only
soon and he also has another Super Chat
c-dub with the fives that I agree with
that a bunch of cheaters online LOL I'm
40 plus so I don't play multiplayer like
that anymore besides sports but only on
console
yeah so I mean but I'm saying like
people have been saying Xbox is about to
become a service only a third party only
I know they have some some games on
other platforms but they're not going to
be only third party they're still going
to make consoles they're still going to
have their own ecosystem see the thing
is is
it makes more sense for them to be a
console manufacturer because they've
already put in the the work they already
have the console the ecosystem the
structure
why would they just leave that it's
easier for them to stay in there put the
r r because they have the brand
recognition
then we'll basically just be a third you
know how much money Microsoft makes off
of services and just a 30 percent
that they get from Publishers and games
in general a lot
Adder you know the thing is let me say
this right quick
all of the the console manufacturers
that failed
Sega right we can talk about NEC with
the turbo graphics 16. Panasonic with
3DO they all have something in common
um their consoles fail because they
didn't have the financial backing
to continue the the like the Dreamcast
was great man but when that PS2 came out
with that DVD player and them great
games it just killed the Dreamcast and
Sega just did not have the finances to
do it anymore they had to
forfeit like we're done
people want Xbox to be in that same
situation if XBox decides to become a
third party it's because they want to do
it they're never going to be in a
situation where oh you know what
financially we can't do the Xbox anymore
and if the Xbox brand is profitable it's
making money
why would they do that so people keep on
saying they're going to do this
they're going to do that no they're not
unless they just choose to
yeah because I think people just need to
understand that Microsoft makes a lot of
money off of that stuff and even though
they might not be first is that stop
like
you know Subway or Wendy's or Burger
King oh we're not McDonald's let's just
shut the hell down you know we don't
it's it's unrealistic you know it what
what's what see everyone talks about
Android and iPhone but what's that third
like the third ones what what's those
companies
like with something I like the Android
phones iPhones
no the the company that makes other
stuff that's not an Android or an iPhone
yeah every every time I like Cricket or
something they have Android phones well
no I'm talking about just the phones
themselves like oh you got my Blackberry
inside my Blackberry yeah pretty much I
think they went to Android now I think
about it
I do think there are phones that that
are loved that aren't Android and iPhone
maybe I'm wrong but it's like even if
you don't use that analogy you know
there's plenty of other stores that's
not Walmart
right that's there they're not just
gonna close down like they compete I get
it they it might be a lot harder for
Microsoft to do certain things because
they're having
some of the advantages they have be
looked at as a negative way such as like
the cloud computing that that the FTC
and the CMA are really going after them
in terms of this cell but it's just like
look like they they must be doing well
they're making money
like they they wouldn't keep investing
into the Xbox brand if they didn't see
any form of return that they knew they'd
get back
it's been years this is definitely not
just the first sum of money that's went
out
they see enough growth where they feel
confident enough to keep investing
and let's be rare people don't like
Microsoft investing money they stole
them for years to invest you're the
richest company in the world why are you
letting this company you know own you
and now that Microsoft has oh yeah we do
have money
how many life
I thought he's like what do you need it
for don't worry about that man we get
you back next quarter we get you next
quarter
all right so that's pretty much all I
want to talk about when it comes to that
because uh when I did see that Nintendo
I did see that it's like you know maybe
maybe there is more that Microsoft can
do in that because you when you look at
the amount of people that loved seeing
that Mario Super Mario RPG
there's other games that Microsoft could
have something similar with
um
all right so let's
talk about
final
fantasy
reviews yeah
here we go I have 31 minutes we 31
minutes we doing good today
31 we might get out of here by an hour
and 20 because I have a feeling that
Xbox raises price is gonna be like a 20
minute topic by itself yeah all right so
let's talk about this Final Fantasy 16
the thing could sit on like an 88 right
now I'm Metacritic something like the 88
89 maybe it went down to 87.
and King is going wild in the IOP chat
talking about
720p
uh do you think that's
when it comes to looking at negative
stuff like
like uh redfall being 30 frames
Starfield being 30 frames and it seems
like people are kind of like ignoring
the 720p and still giving it higher do
you think that's the same or do you
think comparing resolution and comparing
frame rates different entities and
people shouldn't like see them as
together
well
let me get this real quick before we
start okay Lord Metro with the two lost
super Super Mario RPGs a day one for me
looks amazing yes you notice that's 60
bucks what happened to that Zelda energy
but I'm gonna I'm gonna edit there Lloyd
Metro I'm gonna end it there you know
that's one of the most hyped Nintendo
games of all time and they even feel
comfortable putting that sucker out at
seventy dollars I just I noticed that
Lord Metro I noticed that continue dirt
um there obviously there are two
different things but
see listen man
we the last week people I still get
comments on my last couple of videos
people just leaving 30 FPS 30 FPS listen
bro let me tell you guys something
a lot of people
don't talk about when it comes to these
games and this generation you know the
console war we go back and forth with 60
FPS 30 FPS 4K 1080p 720p 720P
I think it's more unacceptable than 30
FPS this generation right oh that's a
bold statement
um 720p bro that's that's 360 numbers
you know the PS3 numbers but my point is
something a lot of people don't talk
about when it comes to this conversation
is it's engines right um some engines
are better than others some engines can
get frame rates much better and easier
than other engines is this the same
engine that's running that was running
uh for smoking because it almost seems
like it
the frame rate it doesn't even keep a 30
like a steady 30 from what I've seen it
drops the quality mode drops the
performance mode
it's terrible
um so what happens now right
it drops to 720P
I'm sorry folks in the attack because I
know I just I just talking right now I'm
focusing the chat
720P
how is 720p okay right now people
roasted Xbox for Starfield being 30.
Starfield listen I'm not saying this
right I'm saying it was Todd Howard and
those guys decision to make it 30.
flat out nothing else we can say
uh Square Enix uh they decided to
run with a dynamic resolution
to get the frame rate steady and the
frame rate is not steady so what do we
so what are we talking about right
what are we going to talk about
is it acceptable for Star field to beat
30 FPS 4K
just to be clear from you this is how
you're going to be looking when you're
playing 720p okay look at this man this
is what PlayStation people right now are
dealing with on Final Fantasy I'm joking
I'm joking my zoom is being messaged to
Zachary stop doing that my zoom's being
messed up give me a couple seconds to
fix that
just keep keep talking to the man feed
them the the truth the gossip Yeah man
so
so for smoking uh you may need to shut
up top on my glasses my glasses ain't
that damn fake you POS but let me tell
you
it's okay these listen these game
companies these development teams they
made the games to their best to the best
of their abilities some engines can cut
it some engines don't right
flat out we've seen great engines uh
uh put out games that run the steady 60
we've seen engines that can't that can't
do 720p a lot 30. we've seen this
720p is kind of crazy because like like
we I would like with the PS5 and this is
a PlayStation 5 only game
right and it's slipping below 1080p one
would think like 1440p 1080s where you
know you would expect this kind of call
tonight to hear me I don't care you know
if it because I think this is one of
those things where it drops it's
probably got uh you know um
um what's what's what do they call that
frame rate and resolution resolution
where it goes up and down depending on
what the game needs dynamic dynamic
resolution that's fine look you know
other people are going to go to gonna go
hard because of the resolution because
that's that's not what they expect from
this type of game me I don't really care
I'll be real with you as long as the
game's fire I'm good with that the
reason that like games like redfall got
like really dragged is because it was 30
frames and it was very underwhelming in
terms of content that you could play but
what I will say is even though I don't
care
it does look very spooky that in 2023 we
have a game
hit 720p on a next-gen console that goes
for Xbox too and this was on Xbox it'd
be like that spooky you know we
shouldn't be because to me at that point
it's like the game's not like unfinished
but to me it's like they should have
optimized it a little bit more
yeah I mean it is what it and I saw
somebody it's not several it drops the
720p sir
I forgot what the pony name was
Satan sauce so that so his name right
there
it drops to 720p sir we're not lying go
look at digital family or whoever else
did the analysis video
it drops to 720p listen 30 FPS was
unacceptable last week but 720p is okay
this week is that what you guys are
telling me
and then we got to be real here guys
like we're not saying that it's like
right or wrong I I don't want people
thinking that you know we we're just
saying that the energy that was going
over 30 frames which is unacceptable
should be hit too when it comes to a
game that can't perform at 1080p
uh you know and that's everything you
know I'm sure some Xbox games do that
too
so let me get these super chats uh it's
JD Gamers I don't think uh we're gonna
get triggered too much you know he
usually comes in with the knowledge ten
dollars ten dollar Super Chat from JD
gamer let's just get this out of the way
how much is consumer social brand
awareness worth
well
billions and that's why Xbox isn't going
anywhere Microsoft was going to buy
Yahoo then Tick Tock then Discord for it
so uh okay I was about to start reading
his next Super Chat okay yeah you you're
right brand recognition is worth a lot a
lot of money there's a reason that
people look at Facebook as not just you
know social media they look at Facebook
as as Facebook they look at Twitter it's
Twitter do you think Twitter was worth
all that money just because you can get
on a tweet notes because it's Twitter
yeah
five dollar super trap from JD Gamers so
no uh to know what a social media
presence and Xbox Live and then Xbox
platform have social media aspects to it
the consumer Market drives the whole
Market I completely agree completely
okay let's get back to the slander let's
get back to the slander
so
first off are you gonna play Final
Fantasy 7 16 let's be bro are you gonna
play it down I didn't even download the
demo bro so so what could you say and
you know we got
377 67 people in here man hit that like
button let's get over 100 likes before
the end of the show uh I'm probably
gonna raise that before the end of the
show but right now we're going with a
hundred man we're going for 100. there
is at least 20 of you that ain't ain't
that like button like don't don't front
with me guys don't front with me so I I
am actually going to be playing Final
Fantasy hardcore so um
you know do you think
that it's one thing
to criticize something do you think
because I know what a lot of people are
going to say they're going to be like
dirt you're not going to play the game
so why does it matter to you what is
your answer to that
[Laughter]
answer to that
what
guys are going to play style field that
criticized Starfield
his father didn't
but I've been this pretty far no so many
people didn't play rare fall listen man
when it comes to this console war banter
that we do come on man everybody's
Hypocrites dirt center for the long run
Dirk's in it for the long run
dirt is an expert at like those long
range attacks you can't touch dirt where
he is I told you in the in the in the
official war zone you know when you just
just realm well I don't know if I call
The Attic show realm because we a little
bit different okay so like viewers just
think of Battlefield okay so right here
is IOP we on the front line we got King
David with this sword going up behind us
is archers and dirt be controlling them
man we'll be dirty like they're coming
on the left line and he'd be getting
those people just shooting them all over
there that's why he got no no [__]
when it comes to his chat okay like they
get close they can't get to his chat
because he is sniping them with arrows
that that is where dirt is right now
I won't hey I won't let him get close
they they try
but now look it's all fun bro but um
yeah but look all jokes aside all jokes
aside honestly
this comes with the territory right
um
720p uh
PS5 only game not even on PC the
strictly PS5
drop into 720P
do you guys question that
you guys want us to question Starfield
and question Todd Howard and question
the power of the Xbox series X y'all
wanting us to question the power of the
Xbox series X you know let me know from
Hit FG blunt
yeah he said dirt snipers be hitting
everybody yeah I gotta actually tell
them to chill a little bit because they
be hitting innocence
though I accidentally hit like like an
IOP Warrior they'll be like hit him in
the in the foot like whoa whoa whoa no
friendly Fighters he's a friend okay
Maddox go help him
yeah man so you know it is what it is uh
but I'm sure you know like people saying
that the game is good they got great
reviews which is great but I'm noticing
um
the game isn't broken it's just the uh
the like the frame rate is everywhere so
look man you know it's getting good
reviews and good for screenings and
Playstation I'm I'm sure it'll sell well
and you know that's good for them
do you think that because here's the
thing like I have my own concerns for
Final Fantasy 16 it has nothing to do
with the you know the uh the frame rate
or resolution or anything like that do
you think okay here's my thing I think
you can easily have criticism
and you could still want to play the
game you know just just because we sit
here and we clown a couple things for on
like PlayStation we both have
PlayStations my PlayStation's in my room
my Xbox is right here because most of
the time when I review stuff or you know
record stuff it's on my on my Xbox
unless I play Playstation I bring it in
here for Final Fantasy I probably will
bring my PlayStation here the problem is
is I don't got too much room on my desk
in case you ain't noticed that
PlayStation is like the size of my desk
so it it it takes me a minute to get
that sucker in here find a good place
for it that's not gonna fall anywhere
and you know it got to the point where I
might need
some of those wall mounts so I could
just put it on the wall mount so I don't
have to deal with anything like that I
don't know I might have to buy like
another PlayStation another Xbox or so
things will be separated it gets you
know I know this is first board problems
but I get annoyed when I have to like
review something and I have to switch
calling so it's like damn it like now I
gotta like I feel like I don't need to
go to the gym because I do that so often
you know when I when I grab the
PlayStation man I I just do a couple of
curls I'm good man I'm good I'll do some
curling
someone sets attic something in here it
was in cat so you are making my dog bark
oh okay my bad guys you know how I get
it yeah I I get into it man I get into
it we got two dollar super trap from uh
kill Walker as Sean says anybody can get
it snipers we gotta watch them in it you
got some very very accurate that's why
King hired them to be the second line
yeah yo we gotta have people Time Warner
here a minute Time Warner here
oh what's up tall Warrior gonna wait for
the PS5 slam uh I hope that the slim is
really how much smaller can you make to
sleep like is it gonna be like the size
of like the PlayStation 5 and it's like
just a little bit smaller are they gonna
try to make like the Xbox version like
I'm kind of curious how small you can
realistically make that because to me
it's big for a reason yeah so remember I
remember the PS3
when they did a slim they made it uh
much smaller
well but that was later in a life cycle
too though so yeah
it's interesting man it's interesting
Final Fantasy amazing I'm so glad that
the game is reviewing well I still I
still have my doubts with the Final
Fantasy brand when I really really jump
into 16.
maybe some of my overall concerns with
the game will be over uh but one thing I
will say and we're not gonna go too much
into this
but you guys gotta relax when it comes
to like attacking people like myself
that prefer turn base
because there's a lot of people that get
so upset with people just because they
want turn based like I get it you don't
care about turn based but you got to
look at it from like the perspective of
the people that play turnbass Final
Fantasy for years yeah we we are getting
a a
a product that's not the way we
originally played it and I know that's
maybe for the good or for the bad but up
until 16 there was a lot of final
fantasies I was hitting misses I'm not
saying that was because of the turn base
I don't think that's entirely because of
the turn base but there is some things
when it comes to the Final Fantasy uh 16
looks like it's it's definitely doing
more Final Fantasy stuff but I don't
think it's doing enough to please the
the ogs the people that came for the
brand the people that love Final Fantasy
you know it's it's making us mad and I
get it to a point it's not your guys's
fault uh but I will say that chill out
on us man let us live
let us live because it's a because the
same people like I put on Twitter the
same people that are complaining about
me wanting turn-based Final Fantasy of
the same people that complained at the
smallest thing is off in a comic book
movie
but I can't want
a gameplay style that I played for like
a couple decades yeah but see like
Dragon Quest Square Enix gives you the
option do you want this newer style
gameplay or do you want turn bass I just
don't understand why you know they can't
do that with Final Fantasy I get it
probably you know make the game more
expensive but it's just like
why are you spitting in the people that
made your franchise what it is because
to me that's what they're doing now
obviously 15 looks like it says 16 looks
like it's going to be fun so I think
that's going to be good I think that's
going to be good the people that say go
play octopath traveler too and all that
stuff shut up
shut up like
same people want final Fant want Call of
Duty to change every year but they do
anything that's not boots on the ground
you complain shut up
oh
okay
everybody my rant is over okay we got a
member chat from Raven blade hey guys so
Starfield I like it hey guys so
Starfield is much larger game uh 4K 30
frames and uh Final Fantasy 16 is this
is a much smaller game is comparison and
720 30 frames which console is the 12
teraflat rdna 2.
30 frames goes to PC to console
exclusive games I'm just tired of
hearing that that the series s is
holding back the X
um I feel you on that there's a lot of
incidences where that's not the case but
I will say from like a foundation level
I've talked to devs that everything
holds everything back you know when it
look they can't truly take advantage of
anything because if in that case they
would just make stuff for like next
year's cars before next year comes out
but they have to make games for
everything for every GPU that's on the
market to a degree obviously the most
popular ones I gotta go back and really
you know fine tune something like the
1080 or 1060 or something like that but
they're gonna try to do the most popular
cards that's on Steam and stuff like
that then you got this because that's
why the the series s doesn't really give
me too much of an issue now if they were
Series S and X exclusives then I would
say there's more to that because then
you're only dealing with the series s
and X you're not dealing with all the PC
counterparts because they're definitely
making stuff on the PC that's weaker
than the series s and they're making it
for those game cards so I will give it
to that uh but the PlayStation 5 Final
Fantasy you know dirt I I was told that
if you work on one con so you you have
the better sis the better game what
happens 720p games
720P
and did you see the frame rate though no
quality mode uh you know
the quality mode was going under 30.
the performance mode which is the mode
that drops to 720P
sometimes not the whole time but it does
drop to 720P
bro the performance mode was pretty bad
it's so bad the digital finder Foundry
recommended plan in quality mode because
the performance mode was so bad it was
dropping all over the place so
it's just one of those things man it's
like look
if you want to play play it I I don't
think we've ever gonna get to the point
where I'm going to tell people not to
play something from performance if
you're okay with playing at those
standards which I am I'm definitely
going to play it then play it man don't
let anybody tell you guys anything
different to our subscribe from the
black John accurate I don't know what
he's talking about
um I'm sure I don't know maybe I'm not
sure maybe he only certain characters of
uh two dollars so maybe he didn't have
enough characters to explain what I
don't know two dollar super trap from
Raiden blade it's not 720 plea it's
knocking on the door of 720p
man they you guys are very very extra
today five and Raven blade there's a uh
the black John you had a lot more I wish
you would have put a little bit more
context behind that accurate I don't
know if you're trying to clown on me for
me saying something is that great or not
I don't know I'm bothered by that man
put in the put in the chat tell me what
you mean by that yeah
from c-dub a 720p game will out still
also anything on Xbox patches will be
made here oh patches oh come on C dub
seems to be a pony man AC dub
you talking like it's 2015 brother it
ain't 2015 no more
PlayStation that shows you all of their
bangers they got coming
foreign
that's funny man that's funny oh man
good old c-dub yeah and at the end of
the day it's like look a good game is
gonna outsell
other games you know Final Fantasy 16 is
probably going to do very well uh you
know according to the metacritics so far
it's a good game but then when you look
at something like uh you know Starfield
from what we see it looks like a good
game that's going to sell well
the performance mode things on the back
end there's going to be some people that
complain about that for the most part
the majority of people are gonna
Overlook all types of stuff if it's a
good game
uh five dollars super trap from uh cdub
I just have disposable income I just
like games I feel you on that well I've
seen that 50 right now since you got
disposable income he don't have that
kind of disposal
look at you you sit there like oh you're
gonna beat your chest beat your chest
show us show us your disposable income
right [__] out of 5200 they're like do
you got McDonald's disposable income or
Chick-fil-A disposable income because
there is a difference
well I don't think McDonald's will have
a dollar menu either oh they don't have
it anymore no I don't think they do well
they got some stuff for cheap big
chicken [__]
ah oh my god oh snap hey I apologize
brother I'm sorry I apologize
I think that's the only person I've ever
seen that just says shut up shut your
mouth hey yo see that I'm shouting my
mouth brother respect to you I'm sorry I
apologize
yo you kind of just got played there you
you just kind of oh my God he can't he
got you there man all right so
let's get to that let's see what we say
like he said split it and buy Final
Fantasy okay I I will send dirt 25 of it
um
let's let's talk about Final Fantasy
um not Final Fantasy let's talk about
Xbox raising the prices
okay let's talk about it brother
okay I'm Gonna Let You Go first because
I got my reserved opinions all the
matter tell me what you think
well I I I got to be honest
um when PlayStation raised the price of
their console you know we made fun we
laughed and now with the game pass price
hike we knew that was coming we all said
you know they would eventually raise the
price of Game Pass and I think a dollar
for the regular Game Pass and two
dollars for ultimate that's not bad now
when it comes to the console price being
raised I was like ah
because I said it from the beginning I
was like if XBox raises the prices of
their console I don't like it I don't
like it at all and I feel that way
um they did the exact same thing the
PlayStation did they raised it in a lot
of places but they didn't raise it here
in the states
I think they said Japan and and a couple
other countries
um so it's at the point it is what it is
some things are inevitable I really felt
that I the Xbox could have just
y'all y'all Microsoft you know this kind
of
take the hit until y'all can make the
consoles cheaper
but they didn't do that but I will say
this they do have because once they
didn't raise the price of the uh s uh
hello hello hello hello okay well I'm
gonna turn my mic down on OBS a little
bit because apparently I'm busting
people's eardrums out continue oh you
don't sound that loud to me yeah so that
so that's how I'm feeling I'm like yeah
I wish they they didn't do it I wish
they could have just kind of took the
hit but maybe it was too much of a hit
to take
um you know like maybe they didn't want
to take the hit up of the Xbox series X
obviously they didn't they did not raise
the price of the S which is good now the
question is will they eventually
discontinue the white Xbox series s
and focus on the black Xbox series
that's with the one terabyte of storage
um so yeah you know it's unfortunate I
don't like it
um like I said the game pass price hike
was not surprising we all predicted that
and the the price hike that it has
gotten for Game Pass is not bad at all
one dollar and two dollars is not bad at
all but damn you know it is what it is
bro
yeah I agree I think that when it comes
to stuff like that we're at a point
where it's like look I still disagree
100 they shouldn't have done this but at
the same time I'm gonna say just like I
said PlayStation what you gonna do
you're not gonna don't buy Xbox like I I
I think that's
the biggest thing I don't like about
this is the same thing I didn't like
about the PlayStation one don't increase
your
your prices in certain areas but not
other areas yeah because to me it's
spitting on anywhere that's not America
because it's like okay we value American
Consumer base so much we're not going to
raise it over there it's like be
consistent make us pay just like you
make them pay it because because to me I
get it you don't want to raise it in
that now if PlayStation would have
raised it in those areas they would have
done it but it seemed like they're
mirroring what PlayStation did because
they they they know they can make
something in those areas it's still a
competition right and to me it's just
like you should have just took the L
um like yeah on the console you should
have just took the L now Game Pass
that's one thing now I think Aaron or
someone said that
they weren't going to raise it during
the holiday sales and people were
correcting me on Twitter
but it's just like you should have just
kept your mouth shut if you guys are
going to raise it anytime like and maybe
he just didn't know that they're at that
time there wasn't no plans for it and
then sooner or later they got to that
discussion they were taking advantage of
plays I remember when it was ax when
like ax feel that it was around the same
time PlayStation raised their prices so
they were trying to take advantage of it
you know
in that moment yeah because to me
just at that point just don't
just don't say nothing you know because
there's a damn word it's it's like the
it's like the 60 frame 120 frame Comet
that that people are just butchering
Aaron with like if you don't yeah if
ever if you were not 100 confident that
you're gonna hit that every time
just don't say nothing
because even though that was years ago
they're still going to use it against
you and
that that's my biggest issue with the
whole thing it's like
to me the Showcase was amazing
it was a great showcase they really
impressed me for a lot of things
obviously I have my nitpicks gave it 8.5
because I felt like combat for hellblade
was very underwhelming there's a lot of
things that that I personally feel I
could have improved but it was still
enough to give me an 8.5 what did you
laughing about that super chat from uh
go ahead and take care of it all good
Olga Bravo with the five so if XBox runs
Starfield to 4K 30 PS5 I'll probably run
Starfield at 360 P30
you're being messy man and that's my
biggest issue with the matter it's like
look
just be consistent with messaging you
know I agree with that uh especially
when it comes to this like you had such
a good showcase
and I felt like you had so much good
publicity
even if you had this plan three or four
months ago and I don't know how
executive stuff worked I don't know how
business to this degree running a
trillion dollar company I don't know
that but at the same time
it's like you've seen all this good
publicity you've seen you being positive
Outlets everywhere I'd have been hitting
up PR I've been hitting up who I had to
talk to is Phil I'm like can we delay
this news
like look we can do it can we do it like
the beginning of next year can you let
me rock the rest of the year with this
good publicity or maybe they have some
really good stuff about to come out and
they want to get the bad stuff out now
yeah I mean sometimes you kind of have
to do that remember we talked about this
last year remember before uh was it
before E3
last year they came out and said that
Starfield will be delayed start feeling
rare fall will be delayed it was like it
was like a premature attack they're like
we know we're gonna get attacked that's
what I felt like they should have did
with Starfield with 30 frames they
should have got that out of the way
before the show that way no one was
talking about that when it happened
people already talked about it you had
the the PlayStation podcast made 50 the
podcast 28 videos in a hundred hours of
of
of uh Twitter spaces all that was over
because it's like I've always said like
like you know
in the real world
everyone drives around like they drive
around a residential area
you know you get to you're going
medium slow pace
and gaming
it's like the it's like the freeway
by the time something happens we we done
10 15 miles up the road like we ain't
talking about this anymore and that's
why it's just like get it out of the way
don't let it be in the news when the
bats thought when the good stuff's
happening
yeah the only thing I would say like
before you get to Super chats
um I still don't think this news is
enough to hurt their I don't know I do I
do think it does bring it down a little
bit I mean very slightly because I mean
his cost was going up is a big is a big
deal I I wouldn't say too much on the
subscription because Netflix does it
like every three months but right
I'm gonna say I think like why is not
hurting as much
um because PlayStation already did these
exact same things because remember when
Xbox announced their first party games
would be 70 we talked about it but it
didn't really shock the world because
PlayStation has already done it it it it
will be uh much bigger not in the
console war yes this is more ammo for
the PlayStation guys
but at the end of the day PlayStation
has already done these price hikes
and Xbox is just following suit so the
the negativity isn't as bad as it would
have been the PlayStation hasn't done it
already
um so it is what it is
I just think that um
Xbox has to continue
with the Positive momentum so like this
news is a little bit of negativity but
it's not like you know groundbreaking oh
no the Xbox is going it's not like it
was a month and a half ago with rainfall
and CMA blocking the deal it's not that
so you know I think it'll be okay yeah
me too me too hey Knicks hold on Nick
shut up
all you do is come through here and cry
complain about what we seeing you
listening to us we ain't listening to
you punk
it was funny is like at least like some
of these PlayStation Fanboys at least
they'd be saying stuff with their chest
they'd be super chatting they'll be like
yo you gonna come at me like some of
these PlayStation fan boys be like I'm
it's like they talking like like some of
these people come in like this is what I
stand on some people could be like yeah
it's like we can't speak up we can't
hear you speak up
uh two dollars from uh hit f g s blunted
uh you know I'm sure there's some form
of an inside joke but we're not going
into that now Starfall will be zero p
and zero FPS on Playstation 5. it's just
a black screen imagine if they literally
acted like they were releasing this game
on Starfield and it's just a black
screen no no no you just had a petition
Nicks did you did you sign that petition
PS5
yo yo imagine if it was
imagine if you downloaded the game right
you go into
on PlayStation and it's just a picture
that says available on Xbox and it gives
you the code
wow you got it like that's what like
like whole code for the game you say
like a digital code for the game
oh we gotta find out super chat from
Alvin I think they raised the prices now
because they said they wouldn't do it so
close after closing ABK now they know
it's about to close so they're doing it
now I feel you but didn't one of like
the uh one of the
the things that I think the CMA wanted
is they didn't want uh they want
guarantees that they wouldn't raise
prices on Game Pass
um I don't remember a guarantee to
saying that no no it wasn't a guarantee
but I remember that was one of
the ways that they were kind of pushing
to get it passed they're like look we'll
we'll be more open to talking about this
happening if you can guarantee Game Pass
won't
uh increase besides like inflation
oh okay yeah well worldwide Gamecast
like maybe that's why the increase was
so small you know
yeah because it was only two bucks I
mean two bucks is a lot if you consider
like 30 million people
um
let me actually we got one more thing to
talk about it's the same thing
yes sir
nah Nix I like you man I like you kind
of well not really but hey it's all good
thanks for being here we just joking
with next he's taking if he's taking
this one too seriously I apologize not
really
all right Nick's cool online podcast he
ain't welcome on my channel
okay okay
okay what's up bro
it was increased by two dollars
on Xbox game pass was there a PC
increase
no there was not so
I think we're at this point where we do
need to talk about Xbox and Microsoft
trading Xbox like second class citizens
uh I do think there is enough valid
proof not obviously not second-class
citizens but they they don't like you
hear you see Phil on here talking all
the time about you know giving back to
the Xbox Community he talked about it
when uh he bought the Bethesda uh the
Bethesda deal uh you know you got
exclusive exclusive games on PC you
don't have them on Xbox you even have
exclusive games on
on mobile that's not on Xbox
do you think we gotten to the point now
especially not playing gold
and they don't and obviously this
increase is not happening on PC it's
only ten dollars on on PCS still do you
think we've gotten to the point where
it's like enough is enough Microsoft you
need to address this and you need to
actually have that same energy I think
more people would be okay with the
increase especially on the Xbox side if
it was if it was on the the PC side to
it I'm not saying you know raise it on
both
because one I'm saying that from a like
a perception wise it looks crazy that
you're raising the same service on Xbox
but not PC let me get this member chat
real quick member chat uh the Elder
Scrolls 6 petition has a four uh 10 40.
uh oh no 1040 signatures to make Elder
Scroll sticks for PlayStation's
Firestone we made a Spider-Man petition
to get them yo put that Xbox on yo uh
neither are gonna happen yeah neither
are gonna happen uh both are pretty you
know comfortable with being on the other
platform at this point if you want that
you're gonna have to go and get that two
dollar super shot from Hit uh it's
hitting field gold blunted
it's hit and fill goals blunted dirt uh
POS Okay so
talk to me dirt because because to me
I'm not mad
but I do feel slighted yeah you know I
do feel a point where it's just like
do we continue to let this happen
because at this
it just feels like they are trying to
push you into PC and I know that's not
the case I feel like they feel
comfortable on the Xbox platform they're
not going nowhere and they're trying to
grow the PC and that's fine but it's
just like if you want to do that you're
gonna just have to take the L on Console
while you grow the PC base and then
raise them both when you feel
comfortable raising on both
yeah first I'll explain difference is
the attic what's my name explain
difference addicts and say I'm not going
to even try to announce your damn name
yeah
uh okay
explain difference
people might not like what I'm about to
say
but this is is my
um opinion
it's it's unfortunate man but
some things in life this is not fair
and PC players
it seems like they get like like they're
like uh I use this like analogy before
they're like blade like you know like
combo big character blade he has all the
powers and the strengths of vampires but
he has none of their weaknesses right he
can do everything they can do except for
he can walk around in the damn daylight
too they're like damn you get to do that
too so he's like PC players they get the
benefit like
they get stuff that we just don't get
like we're getting the uh Rays they're
not
I mean a price hike they're not this
stuff has happened in the past like for
the longest their games didn't cost as
much as console games
not just Xbox Xbox PlayStation Nintendo
PC guys didn't pay as much for their
games as we had to pay
so it's like it's been going on for
years
I see what you're saying like Xbox this
is not fair damn it and it's like wow
you know I'm at the point like it's such
an Xbox like blizzard same way like what
I will say is a PC people is that I
don't like most of you I'm gonna be real
with you because they got cheaters like
maybe because like like so many cheaters
and they don't I will say though that PC
Community got the gaming industry scared
[__] let's say that like like they
scared to move anything to epic game
store they're scared to do any like
major changes to anything they're scared
to raise prices on anything like
you really got them straight and what it
is is
a lot of console Gamers obviously were
vocal but a lot of console Gamers
they're casual they're not vocal right I
do think there's no such thing like
there is casual PC Gamers but I think
they're not the same as a casual console
gamer the facts yeah you have to be
knowledgeable to some degree maybe not
huge but to some degree to play on PC I
feel like on on Xbox PlayStation and and
definitely switch you just gotta buy a
console and just put that sucker in and
I think that
what is a PC person already at what are
they at
they're at a key they have a keyboard
like this thing right here right it's
easy for them to go to a website because
they're already there
so Hey listen you just brought up
something that I actually didn't think
about when it comes to casuals
a cash okay I'm gonna give you a perfect
example my oldest daughter
24 years old she's a PC player now like
she used to be a pony back then they
wish he wasn't a pony but she's a
preferred PlayStation but her like her
boyfriend is this PC guy
smart kid i i t guy he knows he can
build me a PC if I ask him to
he has her on PC now she's a casual she
plays right now is OverWatch too that's
all she plays but he built her a PC
the Casual PC players like her that only
plays one or two games
they usually have somebody build them a
PC or they they're excuse me
they'll buy your PC
like you said if you compare that to a
console casual
they're kind of nine day bro like
a console casual wear it is by the
console sit down and play a PC console
like you said they have everything there
teams come out back the keyboard the
websites
they don't they don't want to pay all
that extra stuff they're not going to
pay all the extra stuff and it's
unfortunate
but it's reality
I know the PC like I said PC gang is
going deep today yeah that PC gang is
you know they are where they are man you
know and but I think attic is right he
said these companies are scared to tell
what the PC guys they have they have
power man
they have power they do the PC guys can
say oh you know what we're not paying
that we're not doing that we're just
gonna steal it
okay you know what we're not going to
raise the prices guys we don't want you
guys to steal it steal the games we're
just going to keep the prices as they
are and it you know it's it's
unfortunate it's unfair but it is what
it is and I said that for the fifth time
today but I'm say it again
it is what it is
yeah and it's like I said I don't agree
with it but at the same time what are we
gonna do you know what we gonna do bro
they gotta Inspire passion and they know
they have inspired passion and they know
they ain't we ain't going nowhere
I had it if if I'm really that pissed
maybe I will become a PC Gamer but we
know that's not happening I don't want
to be a PC Gamer but the option is there
right if I really want to like if I
really want to learn how to speak
Spanish I can download Rosetta Stone and
pay some money and figure out and learn
how to speak Spanish I don't really feel
like doing this dude yeah I can become a
PC Gamer if I wanted to right yeah
and walk off into the sunset you know we
about an hour and 17 minutes walk off to
hey what's up bone slave you half a pony
all right so what what's what's going on
with you uh Darwin what's popping what's
what what do you got going on
nothing much man um you know you know
I'm gonna tell these guys right now if
they try to hit me up dirt keep that
same energy do it do a video about the
Xbox price increase no
I'll talk about it on the podcast I'm
not doing a dedicated video to that uh
no but that's about it man um thanks for
having me oh well I'm the co-host now
but thanks for another show my brother
um I got I'll probably do a dark man
podcast tomorrow it depends on how much
news pop out because I like right before
the show I saw some stuff
um about people really calling out Jim
Ryan calling him a coward for not
showing up in person to the to the
hearings
he said he's going to be on those TVs
that she was showing uh like you know
like Elementary School you're gonna be
on one of them old TVs and it's not even
live it's pre-recorded
he's like you were coming they say he's
a coward uh so yeah
um that's about it man I'll put my
listening guys if you love Xbox content
um trash talking
and like the second line
trash talking he's he's got his his art
like look like there's one of those
things man you know when he's not in
when he's not in battle he got his gates
open but he got those archers over every
time they just like this what you gonna
say oh nothing okay what you gonna say
oh nothing okay oh bam now you out of
here hey uh let me say something next
Nick said dirt your channel would be
fine if you welcome players from all
sides break to Safe Haven you created
for the abuse
listen to me for a second I need you to
understand that I've been there I've
done that
I'm just tired of y'all ponies man
uh listen this is our Lord's podcast
Channel this is this is Lord addicts
show right here this is their Channel
they can do what how they want to do it
but on my channel I've been there with
the ponies coming in and they're too
soon I have an Eco Echo chamber damn it
I keep on telling y'all why do you think
he's in the second line he's tired
I'm tired he goes like I can't do it no
more he gonna let General King be in the
front lines
[Laughter]
it's nice I like it yeah so thanks bro I
appreciate you addict man I always have
fun yeah definitely go over there uh
follow him on his channel man uh pop
into a show but you know I appreciate it
for coming through we're gonna go ahead
and uh slow this out of here uh we was
in there for an hour and 19 minutes we
got 168 likes and 350 people watching
hit that like button on your way out I
know you guys can get that over to 200.
I know you can don't sit there and tell
me you can you can easily get that to
the 200. we ain't we ain't playing with
you guys today uh so someone said is uh
level one gaming I almost didn't send
them anywhere
shout out to fame yeah let me see I
don't know if the I don't think they're
live yet but let's send you guys over to
Davey Jaffe let's send you guys over
there I'm sure yo tell him addict sent
you tell him uh uh addict sent you I'm
just curious what he gonna say so so uh
you know if you guys go in there big
I'll make sure David Jaffe comes back on
IOP I know I know you guys like that go
on that big and tell him that the attic
show sent you I talk to you guys later I
appreciate it for coming through
have a nice day peace out